bonjour mes amis pour prendre un bain de
une demi-heure et j'ai fait une course à
pied de trois minutes
ah oui mais attention trois minutes de
sprint c'est déjà pas si mal
qu'est-ce qu'ils font tous les 3 2 3 4
bonjour françois moins trois ballons
orange a crevé et galeux 17 balle orange
torréfacteur les bleus jouer ça fait bon
jour joue dix huit bouts sont devenus
complètement fourre-tout les trois
bonjour bonjour faisait mais ça c'est ce
qui se passe ils apprenaient à pompe
nous avons compté casimir je retiens ce
à quoi jouez vous je ne jouons pas
casimir nous faisons l'inventaire et je
retiens 15 et je t'assure jeu n'a rien
de drôle l'inite facile oh là là là là
je m'en doute c'est sûrement par phase
sûrement pas et qu'est-ce que vous
inventez alors mais nous n'avons rien
case unir comme en france on vient de me
dire que vous faisiez l'inventeur
timur pas l'inventeur l'inventaire ah
bon il me semblait bien aussi c'est quoi
l'inventaire écoute casimir ça consiste
à faire la liste exacte de 12 ce que
nous savons que marchandise alors moi je
compte mes balles on écoute laisse moi
tranquille bon moi je casimiri femme et
moi je mets bonbons mais car à l'écart a
d'ailleurs fait tout ce que je vois à
céret à quoi exactement de jouer les
machines à calculer à savoir ce qui nous
manque et ce que nous devons commandé
pour sûr au facteur est ce que vous
faites également l'inventaire de vos
goûts reçues il y en aurait trop casimir
ah bon je me contente de faire le compte
de mme éteindre bon ben c'est très bien
tout ça mais moi il me faudrait un
ballon jaune à deux timbres 1 et 5
caramail à écouter zone et casimir mais
quand on fait l'inventaire on ferme
boutique tune a valu la peau qu'à fermer
dans casimir du reviendra demain dit
enfin casimir arrête de parler l'objet
j'arrive bonne concentré c'est ce qui
n'est pas drôle aujourd'hui vraiment un
mois qui vient de la place j'ai pris un
bal délicieux et je vous assure que
c'est beaucoup plus agréable pour passer
la journée à faire des comptes avant les
faits nous pourrions peut-être nous
arrêter un instant le temps d'aller nous
bénit ça nous fait une bonne récréation
salois fraîcheur qui peut les idées un
bon bah écoute et allons-y en vitesse
parce que hélas notre inventaire est
très loin d'être terminée oui trouvait
alors toutes nos affaires nous ne
pouvons pas les laisser ainsi on raconte
julie nous ne t'inquiète pas je vais
rester là moi un vin par jour ça me
suffit je reste et je garderai toutes
vos affaires pas qu'ils étaient très
gentils tient pour la petite haven un
caramel et durable aussi bon ben je te
donnera également un timbre kelvin mais
à propos de méthane acheter les coffee
compte attention c'est si le vent se
lève
comptez sur moi facteurs
merci kg miramas et henry au bal à aude
à la plage or là je commence déjà à
m'ennuyer
qu'est ce que je pourrais bien faire
j'ai une idée formidable ça tu as raison
je lis je n'ai jamais trouvé la mère
aussi délicieuse les regarder mais on
dirait que casimir fait l'inventaire à
notre place c'est vraiment chic de sa
part
ils veulent nous faire une surprise
aussi touchant sa approchons nous sans
faire de bruit poids tous ces ballons
centre le la naphtaline
ah c'est vraiment épouvantable allez hop
tout ça à la mer hop voilà n'en parlons
plus ça c'est un inventaire au le soleil
a fait fondre la cause des timbres bon
allez
voilà les timbres à la corbeille
et voilà à les bonbons des bonbons il ya
va être douce bonbons à la violette mais
ça ça ne fait pas un compte rond alors
11 et 12
voilà pour les enfants je vous avais
oublié tenez venez attendez une seconde
j'aurais vous donner des bonbons servez
vous servez vous bien en étant autant
que vous voudrez et a61 tiens vous êtes
là à ça ça va oui voila je suis en train
de terminer l'inventaire j'ai simplifié
un petit peu un plus de comptabilité
vous êtes contents ils ne disent rien
ils sont sûrement content excusez moi je
viens rendez vous je suis un peu en
retard un jeu soit
[Applaudissements]